should people make New Year's  resolutions people should make New  Year's resolutions if they're actually  watching this video on January 1st if  they're watching it on December 23rd  they should make December 23rd  resolutions waiting miraculously to when  the calendar flips to start making your  life better is silly at best and pisses  me off at worst and so whenever you're  watching this make a resolution every  day of your life because you only get  one app back the reason people struggle  with having a New Year's resolution and  sticking to it is because it was a  tactic to do a New Year's resolution  hence why my first answer was right  which is when you actually decide to  make a change in your life whether about  weight or job or going out with somebody  or relationships that's when you  actually pull it off it's religion not  tactics awesome cool great  amazing you got it